l'attribution des aides européennes se
fait pour des périodes de sept ans ainsi
110 mille projets ont été financés entre
2007 et 2013 pour une enveloppe totale
d'un milliard deux cent mille euros par
exemple pour l'aide aux demandeurs
d'emploi peu qualifiés
la préservation de l'environnement ou
l'installation d'agriculteurs bio à
l'horizon 2020 la somme sera un peu plus
importante
un milliard quatre cent mille euros plus
des deux tiers seront attribués au
développement rural
un peu moins d'un quart pour le
développement régional et aux alentours
des 5% pour le fonds social européen et
la coopération franco suisse pour en
savoir plus sur ces aides est déposé un
dossier la région a mis en place un site
internet dédié europe tirées des fc
point e but
sachez que les collectivités peuvent y
président lui aussi les associations
dans des domaines aussi différents que
le sport la biodiversité le numérique ou
encore les patrimoines le fonctionnement
de l'europe
c'est ce que sont en train d'apprendre
ces lycéens philosophe simulation au
parlement européen